Understanding which alleles influence certain drug reactions has
implications far bigger than just alcohol metabolism. We're at
the edge of a revolution that's about to change
medicine and make it more personalized than it's ever
been before. Imagine taking drugs whose structure and dosing
is tailored specifically to your genotype. Now in this
world of designer drugs there are two main criteria
we need to consider with regards to the pharmacokinetic
an pharmacodynamic properties. The first is efficacy,
or the drugs ability to achieve a desired
effect. The second, is toxicity, or the degree to which a drug causes a toxic
or unwanted side effect. So if we focus carefully and we consider both of these
factors we should be able to tailor
a drug to maximize efficacy and minimize toxicity.